ZDF heute live hallo und herzlich
Willkommen morgen ist es wieder zu weit
zum insgesamt 11 mal hat das Bündnis
Fridays for future zum weltweiten
klimastreik aufgerufen allein in
Deutschland soll es zu weit mehr als 200
Veranstaltungen kommen in verschiedenen
Städten die Forderungen der
klimaaktivisten sind klar Deutschland
muss mehr tun für den Klimaschutz auch
und gerade angesichts der aktuellen
Probleme inklusive Ukraine Krieg und
Energiekrise aber wie lässt sich der
Klimaschutz in diesen Zeiten effektiv
umsetzen und tut die Bundesregierung
nicht in Teilen genau das Gegenteil in
dem sie womöglich Anreize schafft bei
fossilen Energien zu bleiben darüber
diskutieren wir mit Luisa Neubauer von
Fridays for future und dem
Bundestagsabgeordneten und Vorsitzenden
der jungen Gruppe der FDP im Bundestag
Jens teutrine einen schönen guten Abend
ihnen beiden
genannt schönen guten Abend morgen soll
also bundesweit wieder auf die Straße
gegangen werden die Anmeldungen die
allerdings bislang vorliegen dort auf
eine deutlich geringere Beteiligung hin
als noch vor einem Jahr beispielsweise
da sehen wir auch gerade noch mal die
Bilder damals waren es rund 100.000 nach
Angaben von Fridays for future in Berlin
auch Greta Thunberg war damals dabei für
morgen liegen bislang wohl rund 8000
Anmeldungen vor Frau Neubauer haben die
Menschen derzeit andere Sorgen als das
Klima
ja die Menschen haben viele Sorgen ist
belastet die Energiekrise die der
Ukraine Krieg aber eben auch die
Klimakrise wir gehen morgen nicht auf
die Straße trotz der vielen Krisen
sondern wegen der vielen Krisen weil
deren Wurzel unter anderem in den
fossilen Energien liegt in Kohle und Gas
und wir fordern dass diese Krise nicht
länger gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
sondern die Regierung anpackt und die
Krisen solidarisch gemeinsam löst zu den
Anmeldungen da muss man vielleicht dazu
sagen wer sich mit Demo Anmeldung
auskennt also das sind nicht die
Menschen die sich angemeldet haben auf
die Demo zu gehen jeder kann auf eine
Demo kommen und wir werden in ganz
Deutschland auf der ganzen Welt präsent
sein das ist nur die Schätzung die wir
abgeben an die Polizei was morgen
passiert das sehen wir aber dann selbst
ja da sind wir alle gespannt was da
morgen passiert Herr teutrine die FDP
ist seit jeher stolze Verfechterin der
Marktwirtschaft wir erleben allerdings
gerade dass der Staat im Energiebereich
massiv eingreifen muss der Markt alleine
kann es nicht Regeln folgt daraus auch
für Sie dass gerade im Energiebereich
und dann auch im Klimaschutz
vielleicht grundsätzlich der Staat mehr
Einfluss nehmen müsste
naja das ist ja in der beliebte These
dass man jetzt behauptet der Markt hätte
versagt jetzt muss der Staat angreifen
es waren ja staatliche
Fehleinschätzungen wo man sich in die
Abhängigkeit vom Gas von Putin begeben
habe es waren staatliche
Fehleinschätzung dass man sehr lange
auch zum Beispiel
Steinkohle also benziniert ist eine
staatliche Fehleinschätzung von der
Politik gewesen dass man bei den
erneuerbaren Energien nicht
vorangekommen ist weil zu viel
Bürokratie gab also es war nicht ein
Marktversagen was wir jetzt gerade
erleben ist ein Staatsversagen und ein
politisches Versagen ja gewesen und
deswegen kann ich diesen Gegensatz noch
nicht wahrnehmen und selbstverständlich
ist jetzt auch notwendig dass der Staat
entsprechende Rahmenbedingungen setzt
Bürokratie abbaut oder auch
Investitionen zur Verfügung stellt um
schneller voranzukommen
vielen Dank für die ersten Statements
wie immer gilt was unsere Userinnen und
User angeht auch ihr sollt und dürft
natürlich gerne mitdiskutieren und
Fragen stellen per Mail oder über unsere
Social Media Kanäle wir sprechen gleich
weiter mit unseren Gästen vor aber
wollen wir uns noch mal kurz anschauen
worin die Forderungen von Fridays for
future ganz konkret bestehen und wie die
Bundesregierung bislang darauf reagiert
hat
Sondervermögen in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro das bekommt die
Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden Euro also für
Rüstung so ein Sondervermögen fordert
auch Fridays for future für den
Klimaschutz zum globalen klimastreik
fordern Sie einen schnelleren Ausstieg
aus Öl Gas und Atomkraft ein bezahlbares
Bus und Bahnangebot und genügend Geld um
Menschen mit niedrigem Einkommen zu
entlasten finanziert werden soll das
durch eine Kombination aus
übergewinnsteuer für Unternehmen und
einer Lockerung der Schuldenbremse geht
es nach Fridays for future auch die etwa
65 Milliarden Euro an Subventionen für
fossile Energie könnten dafür verwendet
werden unterstützt wird die Forderung
der Klimaschützer aus der Wissenschaft
ein langfristiger Ausblick beim
Klimaschutz sei bei den bisherigen
entlastungspaketen der Bundesregierung
zu kurz gekommen
Finanzminister Lindner kontert auf
Twitter die regierung-
stünden bis 2026 mehr als 170 Milliarden
Euro für Investitionen saubere
Technologie und Klimaschutz zur
Verfügung ob das reicht Fridays for
future hat den Finanzminister daraufhin
zum Gespräch eingeladen um über das
Sondervermögen zu diskutieren
Frau Neubauer nicht 100 sondern sogar
mehr als 170 Milliarden Euro so hat es
der Finanzminister vorgerechnet Stunden
für den Klimaschutz zur Verfügung hat er
sie jetzt eigentlich schon eingeladen
bzw gab es schon ein Gespräch und warum
überzeugt sie seine Argumentation nicht
wir sehen das soziale Sicherheit und
Klimaschutz und unterbrochen
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden auch in
diesen Krisen also jetzt gerade sagt man
oh nie mehr Klimaschutz geht nicht wir
müssen die Menschen entlasten auch aus
solchen Gründen wurde das 9 € Ticket
dann nicht weitergeführt wenn man gesagt
hat nee es war eine tolle Maßnahme aber
wir haben angeblich das Geld nicht dafür
gleichzeitig ist ja absehbar das nicht
so teuer wird wie die Klimakatastrophe
allein die Flut im Aathal hat 30
Milliarden Euro an Schäden produziert
was könnte man mit 30 Milliarden Euro in
Klima in Gesundheit in Kultur in Sport
und Entlastung wirklich machen also wenn
jetzt der die richtigen Investitionen
Klimaschutz fehlen dann ist auch total
absehbar das auch das Geld fehlen wird
um z.B gegen Armut zu kämpfen und
deswegen sagen wir es muss ein
extravermögen her damit diese dieses
gegeneinander ausspielen nicht mehr so
richtig stattfindet und wir sehen auch
dass unter anderem Finanzminister
Lindner in der letzten also in dieser
Legislaturperiode ununterbrochen erklärt
hat dass bestimmte Investitionen wie das
9 Euro Ticket wie aber auch noch mehr
Subventionen für erneuerbare Energien
das ist alles nicht bezahlbar sei also
das Geld ist offensichtlich nicht da wir
müssen auch noch viel mehr tun und
deswegen nein wir bleiben dabei es
braucht ganz dringend das 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen und wenn das fürs Militär
geht dann geht das sicherlich auch für
Klima und echte Sicherheit für die
Menschen die spürbar ist Herr teutrine
wenn sie da gerne wieder möchten also
ich sag's noch mal 170 Milliarden Euro
so hat es Christian Lindner vorgerechnet
warum sind auch Ihrer Meinung nach die
Anstrengungen des Bundes sehr wohl
ausreichend
Herr teutrino jetzt haben wir glaube ich
gerade keinen Ton
kleinen Moment mal ich glaube wir
müssen gerade noch mal oder können sie
es einstellen versuchen Sie es noch mal
Frage an die Regie gibt es da ein
Problem
cool dass wir
eigentlich vermeiden ja jetzt haben wir
sie wieder herzholz-trainer also warum
sind die Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
ja ich bin nicht mehr jetzt hier im
Mikro sondern bei den Airports gelandet
irgendwas scheint nicht funktioniert zu
haben aber sie verstehen mich wieder ich
glaube was ist ja ich glaube an was ist
Luisa Neubauer und future geht ist dass
der Klimaschutz bei anderen Krisen nicht
einfach zur Seite geschoben werden kann
wir haben das vielleicht auch beim
Anfang der Pandemie erlebt dass Leute
gesagt haben jetzt haben wir Wichtigeres
zu tun wir haben es aber auch schon
vorher immer wieder erlebt dass nicht
über die langfristigen Probleme die uns
auf uns zu wollen und die aber auch
schon tagesaktuell mit aktuellen
Ereignissen
Realität sind reagiert wird und deswegen
gibt es die Forderung nach dem 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen weil das
natürlich auch in Zusammenhang mit den
100 Milliarden Euro Bundeswehr einfach
eine sehr gute Forderung ist um
Aufmerksamkeit zu erzielen aber
Christian Lindner hat auch deutlich
gemacht es gibt bereits ein
Sondervermögen nämlich den Klima und
transformationsfonds und wir haben im
Nachtragshaushalt auch sonderschulden
aufgenommen 60 Milliarden Euro noch mal
zusätzlich so beläuft sich jetzt dieser
klimafond bereits auf 170 Milliarden
Euro und wieso wir jetzt vom 9
euro-ticket nicht überzeugt bin das
liegt nicht nur daran Frau neu dass ich
sage naja das Geld fehlt uns nicht ich
finde das ist eine schlechte
klimaschutzmaßnahme das hat nämlich nur
dazu geführt dass 10% der Personen
überhaupt die das Ticket genutzt haben
wo umgestiegen sind vom Auto eine Tonne
hat uns 1400 € gekostet also eine
gesparte Tonne im Vergleich was das
Ticket kostet 10 Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr hat 1400 € gekostet wenn ich mir
Emissionshandel auf den europäischen
Markt kaufe dann sind wir bei einer
Tonne bei 25 €, also man kann für das 9
€ Ticket sein aber bei 100 Milliarden
Euro was sie jetzt noch mal
vorgeschlagen haben allein schon in den
nächsten vier Jahren 40 Prozent davon
für das 9 € Ticket ausgeben zu wollen
was nicht
klimawirksam so ist da und wir an
anderen Stellen mit jedem investierten
Euro mehr erreichen sollten das
überzeugt mich nicht also meine
Zusammenfassung wir haben ein
Sondervermögen wir gehen da auch bereits
voran und die Forderung nach einem neuen
euro-ticket überzeugt mich auch aus
Klimaschutzgründen nicht weil die Zahlen
jetzt nicht gerade dafür sprechen dass
es ein gutes klimaprogramm aber auch
wenn es nachfolgerticket geben wird für
die sich Volker Wissen einsetzt aber
nicht in der Höhe von 9 € gut also jetzt
sind wir schon ganz konkret beim 9 Euro
Ticket Frau Neubauer wenn sie darauf
vielleicht ganz auch konkret erwidern
wollen naja ich habe gerade erklärt
warum man soziale und Klimagerechtigkeit
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen muss das
heißt es natürlich sinnvoll wenn man
eure Ticket erstmal festzustellen
Menschen haben ein Recht auf Mobilität
und dass man eure Tegel hat uns allen
gezeigt Menschen können das aktuell
nicht nutzen weil opnv der öffentliche
Nahverkehr für viele Menschen nicht
bezahlbar ist und das für viele
aktuellen Privileg ist ihre eigene Oma
auf dem Land zu besuchen dass man eure
Ticket alles möglich gemacht das heißt
das rein ökologische betrachten kommt
viel zu kurz da fallen die Sachen
zusammen und genau das sind die Lösungen
die wir so nicht brauchen wo soziale und
Klimafragen zusammenkommen und das
dramatisch an der Lage ist doch mit
diesen 9-euro-ticket das ist ja nur ein
kleines Beispiel da die Regierung
gezeigt wenn sie will kann sie gute
nachhaltige und solidarische Politik
machen die bei den Menschen wirklich
ankommt aber indem es nicht verlängert
zeigt die wir können zwar aber wir
wollen es nicht und das ist schon ganz
schön krass wie am Ende die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen genutzt werden
von der Regierung das ist noch mal eine
andere Debatte was wir machen sind
Vorschläge wir zeigen das Geld ist
gebraucht man kann es sinnvoll einsetzen
und da geht es eben nicht nur um rein
technische Investitionen sondern da rein
zu gucken was Menschen Menschen
tatsächlich eine Unterschied in ihrer
Lebensqualität spüren weil sie anders
mobil sein können nachhaltiger mobil
sein können weil sie nachhaltige Energie
beziehen können und so weiter und so
fort Herr teutrine also wenn wir
vielleicht auch noch mal auf ein paar
andere Forderungen die wir für ihn auch
gerade gehört haben von Fridays for
future eingehen also übergewinne
abzuschöpfen oder Subventionen für
fossile Energien abzubauen um diese dann
umzuverteilen damit auch mehr dann in
den Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien
Invest werden kann oder auch in den
Ausbau des öffentlichen Nahverkehrs das
klingt ja erstmal nicht unvernünftig
oder wie sehen Sie das
ja Frau Neubauer hat jetzt mir
vorgeworfen ich hätte jetzt das neun
Euro Ticket das soziales ökologische
gegeneinander ausgespielt aber mich
überzeugt ist auch in der sozialen Frage
nicht weil es gibt natürlich auch
Mitnahmeeffekte von Personen die das
eigentlich gar nicht bräuchten in der
Finanzierung zum Beispiel hatte ich
selbst einen neuen euro-ticket im Moment
du hattest auch das Beispiel genannt die
Oma im ländlichen Raum zu besuchen im
ländlichen Raum gibt es nicht man ÖPNV
zum allergrößten Teil also mich
überzeugt das 9 euro-ticket nicht auf
vier Jahre gesehen werden das 40% des
100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen ich
glaube wir müssen über andere Maßnahmen
nachdenken das war eine der Maßnahmen wo
behauptet wird ist nur Christian Lindner
blockieren und deswegen finde ich es gut
dass die Bundesregierung besonders bei
den Bürokratieabbau ansetzen das klingt
jetzt nach FDP Streich aber was uns
besonders schadet bei den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien ist dass die
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren zu
lange dauern und da setzen wir
beispielsweise an dass wir schneller
dort werden und ich glaube das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt und bringt am Ende
sowohl Klimaschutz als auch sozial für
bezahlbare Energie und bezahlbaren Strom
sogar mehr als das neun Euro Ticket Frau
Neubauer sie haben heute in einem
Interview gesagt der Regierung sei das
Koalitionsklima wichtiger als das
Weltklima und Olaf Scholz sei ein
fossiler Kanzler bleiben Sie dabei
mich heute wie gesagt in dem Interview
gesagt dass wir jetzt noch extrem
geguckt
also vielleicht noch sozusagen um die um
die Aussage eben einzugehen also so die
die das Klima fliegt uns um die Ohren
wir brauchen eine Regierung die
Vorschläge macht und wenn man sagen
öpnv-konzepte nicht gut findet ja Ferien
NAV aber da muss man ja bessere
Vorschläge machen und zu sagen irgendwie
wir enthalten Menschen
ihre Mobilität vor weil wir müssen
Bürokratie aber machen was sind das für
eine Logik Leute brauchen mehr ÖPNV ist
dann der Mitnahmeeffekt so das große
Problem ist auf der anderen Seite heißt
das Millionen Menschen erstmals sich
richtig frei in Deutschland oder in
ihrer Stadt bewegen können ich meine das
ist doch nicht konsistent und da muss
man sich in dem Augenblick vielleicht
mal entscheiden okay es gibt ein paar
Leute die kriegen das dann eurotheke
dann wenn das eigentlich nicht brauchen
aber vielleicht ist auch das der Effekt
eine solidarischen Herangehensweise und
gleichermaßen wir brauchen doch
letztendlich so ganz dringend einen
Moment wo man die Parteien sich
gegenseitig um die besten Vorschläge
herausfordern und nicht sich ewig
gegeneinander in den Weg stellen weil
das ist ja was wir vor allem in der
Regierung erleben deswegen bis oder
erfahren wir diese Regierung als
dysfunktional und das ganze wird
natürlich nicht besser mit einem
Bundeskanzler der nach einem fossilen
Krieg also der Mast der der möglich
gemacht wurde durch fossile
Energien jetzt um die Welt zieht und
neue fossile Energien einkauft und ganz
klar global in keiner Weise der
Verantwortung gerecht wird und der
Deutschland gerade steht das ist
komplett dramatisch deswegen ja haben
wir riesengroße Sorge um die Rolle von
Olaf Scholz gerade
sprechen wir über die bisher
beschlossenen Maßnahmen der
Bundesregierung die teilweise auch
umstritten sind Stichworte sind hier
etwa der Tankrabatt die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas oder das
Einfrieren des co2-preises wir haben
dazu Brigitte Knopf befragt sie ist
klimawissenschaftlerin und Mitglied des
expertenrats der Bundesregierung für
Klimafragen hier ihre Einschätzung dazu
das sind tatsächlich teilweise schon
sehr problematische Signale die gesendet
werden wenn wir mal anfangen beim
Aussetzen des co2-preises ich glaube das
ist schon ein fatales Signal weil das
Aussetzen des Anstiegs das hat nur ein
ganz geringen Entlastungseffekt also es
entlastet die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht wirklich und auf der anderen Seite
signalisiert das ja einer Klimaschutz
ist teuer den können wir uns jetzt in
dieser Krise nicht mehr leisten das
heißt die eine Krise wird gegen die
andere ausgespielt
also Frau Norbert sie hatten uns glaube
ich auch schon gesagt also nicht die
eine Krise gegen die andere ausspielen
das ist ja auch eine Kernforderung von
Fridays for future
ja
genau wie würden sie das was jetzt
gerade gehört haben von Frau Knopf
bewerten
das liegt jetzt gar nicht irgendwie Frau
Knopf zu bewerten die spricht für sich
selber als Wissenschaftlerin arbeiten
wir unter anderem mit ihr aber auch mit
vielen anderen ja zusammen
gerade in Zeiten wo so dermaßen viel
Populismus rund ums Klima produziert
wird
gehen wir immer wieder auf diejenigen
zurück die sich rein wissenschaftlich
sei es ökonomischer als
naturwissenschaftlich oder physikalisch
mit den Sachen auskennen das ist ganz
entscheidend dass wir jetzt da gerade
hinhören und ich wünschte mir sehr dass
das Regierung auch regelmäßig tun würde
Tankrabatt Steuersenkung auf Gase aber
auch die Reaktivierung von Kohle und um
das vielleicht auch noch mit in die
Debatte zu nehmen die Notreserve
Atomkraft sendet die Bundesregierung da
in der Tat nicht zweifelhafte Signale
ja ich möchte auf den konkreten Beispiel
aber auch eingehen wenn gesagt wird ja
die Erhöhung des co2-preises wird jetzt
im nächsten Jahr nicht stattfinden
welchen Zweck hat in der CO2 Preis er
hat zwei Zwecke das eine ist das eine
Lenkungsfunktion hat nämlich das CO2 ja
Produkte die sehr CO2 intensiv sind
nicht zum Beispiel wahrgenommen werden
aber wir haben ja eine deutliche
deutliche Preissignal also die Kosten
für Energie sind ja schon bereits erhöht
und die Menschen sind schon dabei
einzuspanern jeder Ecke und das andere
ist man braucht zusätzliche Einnahmen
für den Klimaschutz ich habe aber schon
gesagt dass wir bereits ein
Sondervermögen in Höhe von 170
Milliarden Euro hat und deswegen glaube
ich sollten wir schon auch wir sollen ja
Klima und soziale Probleme nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen wie Luisa
Neubauer ja eben wiederholt hat jede
Mehrbelastung ist da auch nicht
unbedingt aktuell angebracht
gleichzeitig handelt aber die
Bundesregierung an anderen Stellen wir
haben mehrere
gesetzespakete durch durch den Bundestag
gebracht das Windenergie auf sägesetz
das Windenergie auch an Land gesetzt das
Gebäude Energiegesetz aber auch das
Erneuerbaren Energiegesetz so das ist
sind jetzt der technische Begriffe und
viele können damit nichts anfangen dazu
wird auch zu wenig in der Öffentlichkeit
darüber diskutiert aber worum geht es da
es geht darum Planungsrecht zu
reformieren Verfahren zu beschleunigen
und wenn sich darüber lustig gemacht
wird dass die Bundesregierung Bürokratie
abbaut das ist das einer der größten
Hindernisse bei den erneuerbaren
Energien dass Leute dass wir da nicht
vorankommen und deswegen finde ich das
ein richtiger Ansatz wir müssen
schneller werden bei den erneuerbaren
Energien wir handeln damit fallen
verschiedenen gesetzespakete übrigens
kein Minister hat momentan so viele
Gesetze durch den Deutschen Bundestag
gebracht wir Robert Habeck aber es geht
auch darum die Grundlast jetzt im Winter
zu sichern deswegen halte ich auch
richtig bei den Weiterbetrieb von
Kernkraftwerken zu diskutieren da sind
wir schon beim Stichwort also wir hatten
es gerade in die Debatte mit eingebracht
der Weiterbetrieb von AKW induzieren 146
fragt uns das auch über Youtube an Luis
Neubauer Neubauer warum ist Fridays for
future gegen eine AKW
Laufzeitverlängerung warum nicht bis
2024 verlängert und nebenher weiter
massiv erneuerbare Energien ausbauen und
in Speicher investieren so seine Frage
oder ihre ja das ist eine wunderbare
Frage ich würde ganz kurz auf
jentes Aussage noch mal kurz eingehen
weil das hören wir natürlich ganz oft
wir sagen Leute ihr wisst was machen und
dann sagen ganz viel aus der Regierung
ey wir machen doch schon und wir machen
doch schon dass es gut aber das ist
Business als usual wir machen doch schon
hätte man letzten 20 Jahre machen müssen
dann werden wir nicht an diesem Punkt
jetzt fliegt uns alles um die Ohren wir
haben alle die Bilder im Kopf vom Reihen
der ausgetrocknet ist vom Ahrtal von den
Bränden in Brandenburg oder vor der Flut
jetzt in Pakistan mit business as usual
kommen wir nicht auf diesen Krisen raus
deswegen brauchen wir seine
maximalbeschleunigung von dem was wir
machen deswegen braucht es auch
teilweise einfach radikale Schritte
tatsächlich ne eine eine Beschleunigung
eine Art und Weise wir ganz schnell von
der Kohle wegkommen können deswegen
dürfen wir natürlich keinen neuen
Autobahn bauen weil wir können nicht mir
Boden versiegeln deswegen muss man sich
jetzt entscheiden nein nicht feststellen
die Terminals zu bauen wohl wissen dass
wir die überhaupt nicht betreiben können
wenn wir unsere Klimaziele einhalten
können ich weiß manchmal nicht was wir
noch sagen können und darauf hinzuweisen
dass es eine Ausnahmesituation ist ein
klimanotstand da kommt man nicht mit wir
machen doch schon und hier Stück für
Stück gehen wir dabei richtig raus da
braucht es neue Wege und da braucht es
einen neuen idealen es braucht neues
Geld neuen Ehrgeiz das ist was man macht
wenn man in der Krise ist und darauf
reagiert dass man jetzt Stichwort
Atomkraft sagt man muss jetzt sozusagen
energiewirtschaftlich was umlenken auch
das ist ja eine Reaktion auf eine Krise
das heißt die Ministerien werden sich
jetzt einigen für irgendwelche
Notlösungen Richtung Dezember aber eine
Laufzeitverlängerung heißt wir stützen
uns noch länger auf eine
hochrisikotechnologie die Katastrophen
mit sich bringen kann im schlimmsten
Falle und wir sind klimaaktivistin weil
wir gegen Katastrophen kämpfen es wäre
komplett absurd auszusagen um von einer
Katastrophe nämlich der Kl Katastrophe
wegzukommen andere Katastrophen man
kauft zu nehmen zum Beispiel nuklear
Katastrophen wenn es doch Alternativen
gibt nämlich die Erneuerbaren die sind
sicher und nachhaltig da machen wir uns
nicht abhängig von Autokraten und gehen
kein nukleares Risiko ein
Ralf Schlösser schreibt uns über
Facebook in jedem Fall hat die
Energiekrise absolut Priorität so seine
Meinung sobald diese vorüber ist muss
ich selbstverständlich wieder die
Aufmerksamkeit auf den Klimawandel
richten und Philipp Sölter schreibt uns
über Youtube wenn wir einen günstigen
ÖPNV haben langfristig großgeschrieben
dann werden viele umschwenken die ein
Auto nicht brauchen es würde den ärmeren
helfen und Mobilität verbessern über das
9 Euro Ticket haben wir jetzt ja schon
länger gesprochen ich weiß es gebe da
noch die ein oder andere Bemerkung von
Ihnen beiden aber wir wollen gerne noch
ein bisschen weiterkommen und einen
weiteren Aspekt noch dazu nehmen zu der
wir auch die Expertin befragt haben das
ist das Ausweichen auf andere Länder um
von dort dann fossile Energien zu
importieren hier ihre Antwort zu diesem
Themenkomplex
Abhängigkeiten von neuen Lieferländern
den wir signalisieren wir brauchen
eigentlich neues Öl neues Gas also das
ist so eine Pfad Abhängigkeit die ist
schon kritisch zu sehen oder auch jetzt
wenn wir LNG Terminals aufbauen die wir
natürlich kurzfristig erstmal brauchen
aber dann ist die Frage sind die dann
fähig irgendwann mal Wasserstoff zu
Transport also an dass dort Wasserstoff
ankommen kann oder nutzt man das eben
länger und hat dann eben so ein Login
also eine Fahrt Abhängigkeit eine
weitere fossile Nutzung von
fossilen Gas geschaffen und das ist noch
nicht so ganz klar finde ich und aus
meiner Sicht könnte die Bundesregierung
da noch stärker die diese Energien
zwischen Klimaschutz und der
Energiekrise heben
Herr teutrino fossile Brennstoffe aus
anderen Ländern importieren weil
Russland nicht mehr liefert womöglich
auch dann das neue Gas mit fragwürdigen
Methoden gewonnen wie etwa dem Fracking
in den USA aber auch wie heute bekannt
wurde Deals mit den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten über LNG
Lieferverträge ist das eine nachhaltige
Lösung
ja was nicht funktionieren würde sagen
zu sagen wir steigen jetzt heute aus
Cola aus wir backen dreckigen keine
Brücken dass wir zum Beispiel auch LNG
Terminals bauen oder aus anderen Ländern
und Gas besorgen ob wir machen keinen
Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke das
wird nicht für diesen Winter
funktionieren es geht darum dass wir
eine Versorgungssicherheit für diesen
Winter auch herstellen und es ist
richtig und darauf hat die
Wissenschaftlerin ja auch bereits
hingewiesen dass die Lösungen der
kurzfristig getroffen werden Stichwort
Wasserstoff oder auch angesprochen auch
langfristig funktionieren und bei der
Debatte um die Kernkraftwerke geht es ja
nicht um eine Laufzeitverlängerung es
geht darum dass es eine Frage der
Vernunft ist in diesem diesem Jahr die
Kernkraftwerke nicht abzuschalten oder
in einen Reserve Reservebetrieb zu
nehmen der übrigens auch kostet der
kostet uns Geld der Reservebetrieb und
gleichzeitig müssen wir auch für die
Sicherheit garantieren sonst eine Frage
der Vernunft dass man dann sagt
kurzfristig müssen wir dort weiter
betreiben geht es nicht um eine
Laufzeitverlängerung deswegen da helfen
jetzt auch nicht weniger Autobahnbrücken
zu bauen und Autobahnen weniger zu bauen
in diesem Winter es geht um eine
Energiekrise und die müssen wir jetzt
kurzfristig da geht es um Existenzen um
wirtschaftliche Existenzen auch die
müssen wir kurzfristig jetzt auch lösen
und ja es ist richtig dass wir bei den
erneuerbaren Energien jetzt auch
schneller werden das müssen wir
zeitgleich machen die Bundesregierung
darf nicht nur eine Hausaufgabe machen
die hat viele Hausaufgaben zu tun aber
das wird nicht reichen und durch diesen
Winter zu kommen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass verschiedene Maßnahmen
jetzt auch kurzfristig ergriffen werden
auch wenn nicht jeder immer zeitgleich
jeden Umweltschützer gleich
gleichermaßen gefallen also ich habe das
vorhin schon beobachtet bei dem Ersatz
mit den AKW und der Vernunft da um
spielte ein leichtes Zucken die
Mundwinkel von Frau Neubauer sie wollen
mit Sicherheit gleich darauf antworten
dürfen sie auch eine ihrer
Kernforderungen ist es ja von den
fossilen Energien so schnell wie möglich
wegzukommen welche
Übergangslösungen wenn man mal so nennen
darf würden sie dann überhaupt
akzeptieren ja es ist so skurril das war
jetzt gerade so exemplarisch wie das
funktioniert also auf der einen Seite
sind sich alle wahnsinnig einig und man
wir brauchen Klimaschutz und wenn wir
dann sagen ja zum Beispiel müssen wir
aus verschiedenen Energien aussteigen
wir haben Pläne vorgelegt wir haben
Studien vorgelegt bei der for future wir
haben gesagt bis 2035 aus Erdgas raus
bis 20 30 aus Kohle raus spätestens wenn
wir das dann alles vortragen was man
denn machen muss und so hilfreich zu
sagen dahin stellen dann kommt sofort ja
aber die Leute haben doch im Winter eine
Krise diesen Winter und wir können das
nicht sofort raus als wäre das irgendein
Vorschlag von irgendwem niemand hat
gesagt ich auch nicht wir müssen jetzt
sofort alle stehen und liegen lassen und
alles runterschalten und dann irgendwie
mit den Konsequenzen legen das ist doch
kein nachhaltiger Übergang und keine
nachhaltige Energiewende oder Klimawende
von der irgendwer spricht und ich würde
mir so sehr wünschen dass wir einmal
diese Krisen mit der Ernsthaftigkeit
behandeln wie sie sind und dann eben
auch hinhören was hier was hier
stattfindet es ist möglich nachhaltig
erneuerbar Fliesen rauszukommen auch aus
dieser Energiekrise und das müssen wir
auch denn wenn wir jetzt weiter in
fossile investieren wie das Frau Knopf
gerade vorgetragen hat dann machen wir
uns ja wieder abhängig und verlagern
nicht so das Probleme die Zukunft
sondern schaukeln ist alles auch hoch
denn die Klimakrise eskaliert ja jetzt
schon das heißt es würde sagen
exponentiell schlimmer das heißt die
Wahl die wir haben ist nicht jetzt ein
bisschen weniger Klimaschutz und dann
morgen mehr sondern die Wahl ist machen
wir jetzt alles um sehr viel
Katastrophen zu verhindern oder lassen
wir zu dass die Katastrophen von allen
Seiten halt ab morgen über uns weg
purzeln und deswegen sagen wir keine
neuen Abhängigkeiten von verschiedenen
Energien außer das was jetzt
zwangsläufig gemacht werden muss
provisorisch diesen Winter das meiste
was die Bundesregierung aber plant
übersteigt das bei weiten und
gleichzeitig braucht es eben diesen
radikalen Einstieg in die Erneuerbaren
der in Tempo und Umfang das weit
übersteigt was wir jemals in diesem Land
gesehen haben es ist halt eine
Katastrophe Herr toll Trainer sie dürfen
gleich antworten ich würde noch gerne
den ein oder anderen Kommentar vorher
vortragen Wilhelm Brandstetter schreibt
uns über Youtube ich schätze dass die
Leute inzwischen kapiert haben dass wir
zurzeit wichtigere Probleme haben als
das Klima das würde ich jetzt mal in
dieser Pauschalität in Abrede stellen
wollen also mit Sicherheit gibt es da
auch andere Stimmen und in der Tat
ernsthaft zum Beispiel schreibt uns
verschafft eurer Stimme einen Raum und
geht für das Klima demonstrieren dann
eine Frage von
Gusti über Youtube an Jens teutrine wenn
kapitalistisches Wachstum offensichtlich
die Ursache für die Klimakrise ist wie
kann man dann als Lösung ernsthaft mehr
Kapitalismus fordern tun sie das
ich würde sagen die Energiekrise die wir
gerade jetzt haben ist kein
ausflugskapital des kapitalistischen
Systems ich hatte das bereits
beschrieben an wie vielen Stellen das ja
politische Fehlentscheidungen waren
gestartet in welcher
energieobjekt in welcher Abhängigkeiten
wir uns auch begeben und wenn überhaupt
dass die Bundesregierung zu viel und zu
stark auf fossile Energien setzt das
Gegenteil ist das sogar der Fall in der
öffentlichen Diskussion die Diskussion
ist das sogar reicht das überhaupt was
die Markierung unternimmt damit wir gut
durch diesen Winter kommen reicht das um
auch die Preise bezahlbar zu erhalten
und deswegen kann ich den Vorwurf der
gerade erhoben wurde von Luisa Neubauer
das ist eigentlich zu viel für auf
fossile Energie gesetzt wird auch
bereits für diesen Winter einfach nur
zurück weil sie ist zuerst Gegenteil der
Fall wir müssen noch mehr tun um durch
diesen Winter auch gut durchzukommen ich
möchte aber auch auf den anderen
Kommentar eingehen dass die Leute merken
dass das Klima das Klimaschutz
eigentlich egal ist und endlich geht
jetzt wieder mal um andere Themen in der
Diskussion da möchte ich explizit aber
auch Unterstützern dass das auch eine
falsche denke ist eine falsche denke zu
sagen oh zum Glück müssen wir uns jetzt
nicht mehr mit dem Klimaschutz
beschäftigen und jetzt können wir uns
mal wieder auf andere Themen irgendwie
kümmern und da hat Luisa Neubau noch
einen Kern
berechtigtem Punkt das ist doch auch
eine verfehlte Politik der letzten Jahre
waren wieso wir in dieser Krise und
dieser Energiekrise gelandet sind weil
wir uns und von Autokraten abhängig
gemacht haben und deswegen kann ich die
Sichtweise nicht nachvollziehen und
halte es für notwendig auch im jede
Maßnahme zu fragen ist die wirklich
notwendig jetzt kurzfristig zu durch den
Winter zu kommen und welchen Beitrag
leistet sie aber langfristig oder
mittelfristig um auch klimaneutral zu
werden das ist das Ziel der
Bundesregierung und daran werden wir
auch weiter gemessen werden ja dann
haben wir doch da schon mal einen
gewissen Konsens erreicht das doch mal
ganz erfrischend und das nehmen wir
gerne mit außerdem wollte ich noch auf
einen Aspekt mit ihnen zu sprechen
kommen es stellt sich ja die Frage wie
die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher vor
einer finanziellen Überlastung geschützt
werden können die Angst bei vielen
Verbrauchern ist ja dementsprechend groß
auch dazu hören wir noch mal die
Einschätzung von Brigitte Knopf
wir brauchen die Entlastung aber wir
können sie eben nicht glaube ich in der
ganzen Breite der Bevölkerung bezahlen
und wir müssen gucken dass wir uns
konzentrieren ob die die wirklich
betroffen sind also untere und mittlere
Einkommen und vor allen Dingen Haushalte
mit Gas an also mit Gasheizung also das
ist doch noch mal sehr wichtig hier zu
fokussieren welche Gruppen können wir
entlasten und das zweite ist wichtig
dass man die Entlastung so aufsetzt dass
sie nicht den Anreiz zum Energiesparen
kontrakariert und das würde bedeuten
dass man halt eher guckt dass zum einen
nicht einfach ein grundkontingent sehr
sehr billig ist sondern dass man schon
sagt das kostet was aber ihr werdet dann
auf der anderen Seite entlastet über
eine
energiepreispauschale zum Beispiel oder
für gasgründen eine eigene
gaspreispauschale
Herr teutrine werden mit den inzwischen
drei entlastungspaketen der
Bundesregierung allein das dritte kostet
ja rund 65 Milliarden Euro wird da
inzwischen für genügend Entlastung
gesorgt jetzt noch mal explizit aus
dieser Perspektive
ja gerade wurde auch angesprochen welche
Gruppen im Blick genommen werden müssen
es müssen die Menschen in den Blick
genommen werden die beispielsweise von
Sozialleistungen auch abhängig sind wir
unterstützen die durch eine
bürgergeistreform durch Einmalzahlungen
aber die die Krise und die
Preissteigerungen gehen ja bis zur Mitte
der Gesellschaft deswegen ist auch
richtig auch bei den Steuerentlastungen
oder wenigstens mehr Belastungen zu
verhindern zum Beispiel bei der kalten
Progression und wir haben unglaubliches
Volumen aber am Ende wird der Staat
nicht alles abfedern können und wir
reden jetzt von einzelpersonenhaushalten
das hat ja auch große Konsequenzen für
den Mittelstand für viele Einzelbetriebe
die auch die Frage stellen ob sie ihre
Rechnungen überhaupt noch bezahlen
können oder da braucht es ebenfalls
Unterstützungen also ist eine ganze
Menge die notwendig ist um da der
schlimmste auch abfedern wir handeln das
schon nicht jede Maßnahme die die
getroffen wurde war immer treffsicher
das muss man ja auch sagen einige haben
in der Breite eher gewirkt aber einige
sind auch sehr genau gewesen und ich
glaube es ist gut dass wir weiterhin die
Preise in den Blick nehmen dass wir
weiterhin bei Entlastungen auch ansetzen
aber gleichzeitig müssen auch die
Ursachen also für die Inflation im Blick
behalten werden und dass man dagegen
angeht damit es keine weiteren
Preissteigerungen gibt also Herr
teutrine räumt selbstkritisch ein
sozusagen für die Bundesregierung das
ist der Maßnahmen gegeben hat die nicht
zielgenau genug waren von Neubauer wie
sehen Sie denn die bisher geplanten und
beschlossenen Entlastungen bzw was
fordern Sie
ja wir haben das auch im Rahmen von
unserer 100 Milliarden Forderung
thematisiert die Menschen sind
unglaublich belastet überall und das ist
präsent und das erdrückt dieser diese
sorgen die sich gerade auf stapeln und
da stimme ich ganz so Trine zu Grund
oder ursache dafür ist natürlich dass
das Handling mit den fossilen Energien
unsere Abhängigkeiten und da müssen die
Menschen jetzt geschützt werden die
Entlastung bisher zeigen dass sie
einerseits nicht ausreichen und vor
allem nicht genau die treffen die am
meisten jetzt entlastet werden müssen
und wir als Schweizer future bewegen
sollen eben auch ganz explizit man muss
auch dafür sorgen dass die Belastung
sinken dass wir wegkommen von den
fossilen Energien und dass wir jetzt die
Form der Entlastung es hat Brigitte
Knopf vom MTC ja auch gesagt dass die
Form der Entlastung so ist dass sie
nicht durch zum Beispiel sozusagen
fossile Anreize also Anreize jetzt mehr
zu
verbrauchen dann andere Krisen wieder
aufschaukel das muss ja zusammen gedacht
werden und ehrlicherweise so von jedem
Achtklässler wartet man das verschiedene
Schulfächer irgendwie gleichermaßen
gehandelt werden können ich glaube es
ist auch in Ordnung von der
Bundesregierung zu erwarten dass Krisen
gleichermaßen zusammengedacht werden und
gleichermaßen ernst genommen werden und
dass wir jetzt Krise nach Krisen nach
Krise sei es Corona sei es Krieg sei es
Energiekrise jedes Mal für dieser Frage
stehen oh fällt jetzt das Klima hinten
zurück das doch kein Naturgesetz das ist
eine Entscheidung der Regierung dann dem
Augenblick irgendwelche Entschuldigung
zu finden da bin ich ganz bei Jens
Vertriebe das darf überhaupt gar nicht
stattfinden und da kann man auch keine
Entschuldigung für finden Thomas
Schönberger fragt uns über Youtube wie
stellen wir denn sicher das nicht nur
Deutschland diesen Winter irgendwie
schafft sondern das auch viel ärmere
Länder in Europa und weltweit nicht im
Stich gelassen werden da hat Fridays for
future auch eine klare Position
vielleicht gehen sie da noch mal kurz
darauf ein
das haben wir auch mit gefordert dass
Teile von diesem Sondervermögen genutzt
werden für unsere internationale
klimafinanzierungen so nennt sich das
also dass Deutschland anfängt in dem
Sinne die klimaschulden zu begleichen
die wir einfach haben bei den Ländern
die heute praktisch die Folgen von
unseren Emissionen ertragen müssen also
Fluten wie in Pakistan gibt es ja in der
Stärke und der Intensität immer mehr
weil Länder wie Deutschland so
wahnsinnig viele Emissionen produziert
haben pakistan hat nur ein Bruchteil
dazu beigetragen das ist total ungerecht
und deswegen müssen wir eben zum
Beispiel mit Finanzierungen einerseits
jetzt helfen wenn Notlagen da sind aber
eben auch langfristig anderen Ländern
dabei helfen sie unterstützen dass sie
ihren eigenen Klimaschutz umsetzen
können und dazu gibt es noch ein
Instrument und das ist total wichtig
gerade das sind sogenannte
energiepartnerschaften das heißt dass
ich Länder wie Deutschland oder aber
auch die G7 oder die EU mit anderen
Ländern zusammen tun wie das jetzt in
Indien gemacht wird oder in Südafrika
und man gemeinsam praktisch so eine Art
Energiewende umsetzt und sich dort
richtig an die Hand nimmt aber auch da
das funktioniert natürlich alles nur
wenn wir als Deutschland da authentisch
sind wenn wir selbst rumreisen die
Klimakrise weiter befeuern herr Scholz
reist um die Welt kauft neues Gas ein
wir kriegen das selbst nicht auf die
Kette wie können wir dann den Ländern
die heute so sehr betroffen sind ehrlich
in die Augen gucken und sagen wir meinen
es ernst mit euch wir wollen helfen wenn
wir unterm Tisch die ganze Zeit gegen
Schienen eintreten
treten wir unters oder unterm Tisch
Forst Schienbein wie ist ihre Erwiderung
darauf letztlich
jetzt gab es ganz ganz viel Einigkeit
ich will noch mal sagen wieso ich bei
den Sondervermögen nicht dass ich
grundsätzlich skeptisch bin ich habe ja
gesagt wir haben einen vorbereitet
eingerichtet aber was ich nicht ganz
ganz sauber finde ist wenn jeder Euro
hier mehrmals bereits ausgegeben wurde
also es war ein Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro für die nächsten drei
Jahre werden das beim 9 € Ticket 30
Milliarden wenn ihr 14 Milliarden noch
fordert für andere Länder
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen das war meine
Forderung aus dem Herbst dann sind wir
schon bei 70% des Sondervermögens was
ausgegeben obwohl er dann kommen noch
Entlastungen dazu dann haben wir noch
kein bisschen investiert in erneuerbaren
Energie also mir kommt das vor ich finde
das gut das Druck gemacht wird aber und
das auch der Druck kann auch sein man
muss mehr ausgeben aber für die
Forderung die alle noch gleichzeitig
haben auch 100 Milliarden nicht
ausreichen ich habe versucht das mal im
Vorfeld heute auch zu überschlagen ihr
bräuchtet er 1000 Milliarden Euro um
alle Euro Forderungen tatsächlich
umzusetzen hier mit diesen 100
Milliarden Euro sondervermö verknüpft
wenn es überhaupt für vier Jahre reichen
soll
wir sind die letzten die die Regierung
davon abhalten würden noch mehr Geld in
Klimaschutz zu stecken also Leute legt
los go ahead wir machen hier Vorschläge
wir machen ohnehin und Job den wir gar
nicht machen sollen würden weil die
Regierung dasselkängst tut in dem Sinne
ich freue mich über alles macht 100
Milliarden hatten wir aber auch eher
gedacht für ein Jahr
okay dann hatten wir das jetzt auch noch
mal am Ende klar auseinandergerechnet
und 100 Milliarden für ein Jahr wir
lassen das jetzt mal so stehen die
Rechnung von Herr tortine kann ich jetzt
auch nicht überprüfen ich danke ganz
herzlich für diese Regel Diskussion
Luisa Neubauer war das von Fridays for
future und Jens toll Trainer
Bundestagsabgeordneter der FDP ganz
lieben Dank und einen schönen Abend nach
Berlin
jo und dann natürlich auch noch vielen
Dank an unsere genau so macht er vielen
Dank an